hey everybody uh you are on Gamespot I
am here with Mary and Chris and I'm
Alexa for those of you that don't know
and I'm here with Robert producer at
Crystal Dynamics we're going to play
Laura coft and the Temple of Osiris now
this is out this week uh actually next
week next Tuesday next Tuesday so this
is coming out soon and what are we
showing off today so today we're going
to be taking a look at uh about the
first 90 minutes of the game uh so we'll
kick things off with the tutorial and
then try and get through the first boss
in the game and uh of course have some
uh nice coopertition playing for people
on the couch cooption cooption I've
never heard that before but I like it
everything will go very smoothly I'm
sure of it oh sure sure just remember
why drops bombs and uh yeah okay why
drops bombs so yeah we could just jump
right into it um first thing that you do
is uh obviously you get to choose who we
want to play as I got dibs on Isis which
greedy Dragon am I I can't figure it out
go left and right until you know that
you're moving a lot oh that's me all
right all right we're good to go all
right I'm Isis who are you Robert I'm
playing as horse he's the one that's uh
going to be
blue Alexa I'm Carter and you are I
believe I'm Lara all
right so we'll go ahead and probably uh
skip through the intro video here just
so that we could jump into the gameplay
but uh the short backstory behind this
is that uh Lara uh and Carter uh who's
like a rival uh treasure hunter they're
both searching for the Lost Temple of
Osiris Osiris was this good king of
Egypt uh his brother set overthrew
hacked his body into multiple pieces
spread it throughout the tombs of Egypt
rude um exactly yeah very rude and uh
long story short Carter sets off a trap
we're Marked for Death and we've got
Isis and Horus uh the wife and son of
Osiris uh who are going to help us find
all these pieces reassemble him and use
his power to uh banish set back to The
Under World great all right so uh all
jars Must Die easy easy with that why so
you've already found the bombs those
come in handy those are the those are
the only things in the game that'll do
any friendly fire so you could shoot at
people don't worry about you know uh
that's pretty awesome so that's your
grapple that be come in handy and then
yeah you could use x to uh roll on the
ground so uh between our four characters
that we have here you can play the game
in any combination of one two three or
four players um but we have two
different classes so our archaeologist
friends Lauren and Carter uh they both
uh using your left bumper you've got a
torch and you could use that to uh light
up things like these braur here you're
welcome guys light the Braes mine mine
mine okay damn it all right W nice
learning how to light
brazers and then uh of course we've all
got uh some weapons at our disposal so
uh our Egyptian god friends if uh if you
hold down uh if you aim with the right
stick and then hold down right trigger
uh that's how you could shoot uh your
weapon so you can break things like pots
they drop things like uh gems Health
packs uh the gems come in hand you
that's actually currency you want to
collect that that so this this is
actually a rift from it's the oh you're
going to totally die I'm you're totally
dead so that's a riff from the
underworld we actually want to use the
the staff of Osiris uh in order to seal
those up later on the game like enemies
will start spilling out of them from the
underworld uh but this being the
tutorial we want to keep it easy on you
for your first few minutes at least I'm
back
baby um all right so this leads us to
our first little uh quick uh shooting
tutorial so we got these four little
platforms here all
right if we all stand on top of it
should unlock this guy I'm being
cooperative sorry see yeah all we all
just have to take a turn uh shooting at
the eyeball in the middle there so first
up we got Carter um down the bottom left
so aim with the right step you used
bombs no I used a bomb and died so if
you aim with the right stti towards it
and then hold down right trigger uh you
should be able to shoot at that there
you go
perfect and then we've got Isis up next
eat Osiris beam this is one of those uh
examples of like obviously this room
it's right now set up for four players
in there but if you were to play this
with any other combination of players
one two or three players uh the puzzles
in the game and even the combat will
retune itself according to experience so
cool and that includes like putting the
you know putting spikes in a different
place putting ring like environmental
like ring elements or pressure plates in
different places right yeah because uh
if you were playing in single player uh
Lura would uh she'd actually have the
staff as well M um so she get all the
abilities of the characters but when you
start throwing in three or four players
you want to make that each of those
players something to do that you're not
waiting on the other players to do
something so we add in additional puzzle
elements just so that uh everybody has
uh a little something to do I wasn't
done looting
um it ours or is it shared amongst the
grou so all the gems that you're
collecting those are individual too you
probably see at the bottom of the screen
we've got uh your HUD and it has a
little score on it um so we're actually
competing against each other we still
have to work together on this adventure
but things like gems we can use those to
open up treasure chests and get loot for
ourselves uh and we don't share that
with the rest of our team it also seems
like most of our weapons are rang not
like there's no melee yeah so all the
weapons in the game are rang they're
everything from you've got uh dual
machine pistols uh chain guns rocket
launchers grenade launchers so if you
ever wanted to see an ancient Egyptian
god with like a submachine gun yeah this
is this is the game to play for going to
be living the dream right now yeah so
that's actually set uh he's our big bad
guy um is he the guy that distributed
body pieces everywhere yes he's the one
who hacked up his brother and and spread
all those pieces and of course he's
raising his Undead Army here watch the
bombs Alexa
no y I'm looking at you kid all right
they're dead and while we're raiding
these tombs here uh we've got little
things like um for instance if I uh
shoot this orb over here it'll unlock
this uh first uh Red Skull so we have
challenges throughout each of the tombs
like for instance they five of these
skulls that are hidden in each of the
tombs and when you finish a challenge
you uh you actually get um additional uh
rings and amulets and other items see
our Egyptian friends uh with their left
trigger they can actually interact with
anything that has that glyph on it so
raising platforms uh smik uh some spike
traps later on the game that was not me
that was not
me um yeah I'm kind of getting like
besides the fact that there's uh no
melee like I get a heavy Gauntlet feel
from this which is um such a good way to
invoke camaraderie between friends and
yet also grab grab grab for yourself
it's such a good feeling so it's it's
good to work together and then also uh
Dart the gems so you can you got to
light these brazers people well actually
uh look uh Carter uh actually figure out
you've got this grapple hook so the cool
thing is the rest of us like the
Egyptian gods we don't actually have uh
a grapple hook so if you if you shoot
that line up there again the rest of us
can actually jump on top of it and tight
rope walk up and leave me behind no then
you can just move right into the wall
and then uh both you and Laura have a
grapple and if you just walk up against
the wall you can just climb up oh yeah I
think it's RB
bye all right your turn there you go
perfect and then you could just move
right towards the wall and uh yeah just
hold it down you could climb right up oh
I look good so yeah it definitely does
have that vibe in there and then the
great thing is we also mix in a lot of
puzzle elements into the game a lot of
great platforming ones uh to help out
with that sort of stuff the Egyptians uh
they also have this uh Magic uh sphere
that they can go into and then the other
players can jump on top of it in order
to get a boost uh up to the higher
areas there you go yeah look at these
little
orbs how do we how cool how do they get
up here give me the grap yeah you guys
are actually going to have to use your
grapple in order to uh pull us up onto
the ledge up there catch the grab you
catch the grab grab me no there we go
come on in grab yourself I'm grapping so
hard the grapp is pretty cool like in
the
like if AER in the you can actually
shoot the down and pull
out I'm surrounded in bugs you do
something nice do we have a bomb counter
uh so you have unlimited bomb so there's
just a short delay on it um but at the
end of the the level we actually track
how many bombs you actually dropped in
there there we
go I got you oh wait no I don't it's all
good we're good we're good
wor so in theory you could play this
game alone but it's probably not as I
don't know a little more difficult would
you say um it definitely gets easier
when you're playing it in Co-op uh for
instance if uh one of you to die right
now um we could actually yeah exactly I
could just go over to you I could hit B
I could revive you and you're back up on
your feet thanks buddy um or just like
about a 5-second delay and then you're
able to respawn in um but if you're
playing in single player if you die it
would do a checkpoint reload just back
to the beginning of that room and then
you'd pick up from there I think that's
health over there it does get a little
bit more chaotic though bombs yes it
does get a bit more chaotic playing with
four players um bomb
time right into the spike pit damn it
guys oh you just got I didn't even do
that there we go God damn it treasure
bomb so bad go away spider bomb
University go away bomb so hard
you give me the loot give me the loot
all right so we got another one of those
uh yeah another grapple ring right over
there perfect and then the rest of us
can just jump on the Rope now will I hit
the spikes if I I feel like I'm going to
hit those spikes don't walk into it you
got to wait wait for what there's
another area over here what's that cross
yeah so uh you're right if you were to
try and swing across you just hit the
spikes but if you were to Grapple up to
one of us over here you'd be able to
just jump with a and you could swing
across the wall why did I do that why
did I do that you got this let's go oh
my God and then just keep walking up the
wall all right swe Lo loot loot loot
loot loot quick loot everything if want
to totally troll you can like drop a
bomb and then blow them off the edge
again but uh it's okay you're the best
my God it's
okay all right oh you know I roll toward
challenge going for the loot here yeah
those uh Point challenges usually if you
get the gold uh Point challenge it
unlocks a new weapon but this first uh
pickup that we have here this is
actually a ring so if you hit the a
button right now you could equip the
ring you notice it'll give you
additional weapon damage but at the cost
of Defense so there's a whole bunch of
rings there's over 200 some odd
different types of rings in the game and
they do everything from like rings that
increase your bomb radius uh to ones
that do more damage or increase your
rate of fire cool uh once you have it
equipped you could just uh hit the B
button we'll back out and keep going on
the adventure there what does my tank
top it looks like you can equip other
yes so we do have uh different outfits
uh in the game as well uh some of the
pre-orders for instance you could get uh
d sex costumes Hitman costumes um so
yeah those are pretty sweet and Tomb
Raider uh Legend costumes as well so
Carter would look good in a red tie oh
he totally would oh yeah he looks good
with a with the agent uh the Agent 47
outfit it would match his eyes so uh
yeah like uh Isis she has a like a
business suit on and then uh that's cool
Lara she's still got uh she's got the
suit but uh of course they dual pistols
and everything thanks I got this can I
take out these at all
you blow them yeah so if you drop y use
the bomb yeah there you go you can just
blow it
up one more time already there you go do
it all right woohoo woohoo oh no okay
you're good all right and then uh yeah
you could use these uh Magic Shields to
block those uh those Arrow shots
skeletons run sure my Arch NE
skeletons anything but skeletons someone
blow up those arrows oh I'm taking I'll
do it damn it totally totally got you
there we need to communicate
better watch out here's my communication
anytime you see a big glowing yellow
circle don't stand in
it cuz that's my bombs I feel like
you're not communicating very yeah we
got another one of those uh grapples
down
there how do
I there you go everybody anyone going
over totally TR and like drop me into
the spikes if you want to but nah you
came all this way I'm not going to not
coopertive not going to do
that do you need to come back mhm you
sure I could use a lift all right oh
jumping oh
you not only blew you up but you went
flying into the
spikes I'm sure you're going to get me
back in a little bit so I feel like I'm
the like dumb sidekick keep dying what
an
idiot he keeps it interesting come on
can't let you get all those gems because
once you get to the end of uh oh this is
uh Amit she's the Egyptian devour of
souls so because we're Mark for death
she's coming from the underworld she's
she's a croca HIPPA lion according to
Wikipedia alligator into the wig store
I'm dead my God
almost Carter made it should made you
made so here you can use x to roll
underneath here rolling is pretty cool
because if you keep rolling around you
noce your character will start speeding
up doing like cartwheels and flips and
stuff so you could use that to catch
up trying she's
trying all right it's a gun yes it's a
brand new gun gun gun gun gun gun we
have to figure out how to get over there
so we got these little cages here what's
this what's this oh so uh yeah uh so
that's got another one of those glyphs
on it uh that the Egyptians with their
uh left trigger there they could raise
it looks like we have a little platform
that we could jump to or fall off and or
fall off God there you go Lara's got it
this was my major in college there you
go so yeah um if you played uh Guardian
of Light you may have remembered there
were a lot of those uh rly ball puzzles
in there so that's actually sunball that
we could use so you could either push it
with a holding down b or you could drop
a bomb actually and just blow it off the
uh well obviously there we
go there we go all right and then uh
yeah we have those little cages over
here and then uh there's also uh up here
we've got another one of these red
skulls that we can uh jump up
to y yeah you guys found the other
one oh no that gem fell to the ground IR
responsible gem collecting you can
always try and go after it Chris you
knew that I was here I'll
help I'm roll this right over
you I'm helping
need a got
it all right we can put that into a cage
and uh Isis you don't want to stand
there yeah I can't
move he was a good man but this gives us
our first uh weapon that we could
collect so uh all your default weapons
in the game unlimited ammo but these
special ones once we equip them here you
could just hit a um we can bind it down
there so that's your uh d-pad right
there um so for most of us think we put
in d-pad uh down there nice and uh we
could switch over to our Submachine G
gun time don't worry guys I'm back oh
God I ran right through them I was
really
worried don't foret you do have the
bombs that you can use in combo get away
from me go away okay what's that no
God this is what I get you're a cowardly
Tomb Raider we got a bag of TS there too
the worst Tomb
Raider the little Tomb Raider lit every
one of them
gems that's okay we got more give your
treasure speaking of
treasure that's a little ammo box there
oh so uh these are amulets um so these
are pretty cool those uh rings that you
have those for yourself but uh your
amulet actually gives you this uh
special ability so it could be things
like uh for instance ones that we'll
have here are fire projectiles it'll um
give you fire damage or you could do
scatter shots it'll actually do like a
spread shot on your shots amulets that
will give you like ammo regeneration
Powers uh leech powers where you could
steal Health from enemies um and uh once
you fill up this uh meter that you have
down on your HUD uh it activates the
amulet and you share that with the rest
of your group so if you're playing like
in co-op with a bunch of people either
online or on the couch you might want to
change up your amulet so that you might
have ammo regen I might have fire damage
so that we have exactly you're kind of
making your own custom class basically
from uh being able to equip ready do
they automatically go off or does there
so like right now uh we gave you a
little freebie there you notice how
everybody down there got the little
lightning bolts uh going on the HUD um
but there's a meter on the left side of
it it's full right now um and uh
whenever you collect gems whenever you
kill enemies anything that scores points
it uh fills up that meter but the second
you take damage uh you'll lose that uh
that meter okay so the goal is to stay
away and take no damage to do the max oh
no what are these guys doing and if
you're griefing your friends
uh that's one of the things that helps
keep you from doing that because they're
sharing that ability with you um and of
course you don't want to lose that
because uh it can make it pretty
powerful so yeah notice like those
little brazers that Laur and Carter can
light on fire we can actually shoot at
them uh with our fire be no not today
this isn't your day
Beatles I like my scatter shock power
should not have walked Isis you're
totally rocking the points there yeah so
you just completely the gold challenge
where am I does that mean I got what
happened oh I'm down there yeah you're
right down there oh my
god get up there yep just got another
one of the uh the grapples there and
just like with your guns you can
actually oh yeah oh you son of a who did
it now he that was red now we all lost
fire bullets I hope you're happy sh did
that laara is a you are totally
right God I'm on the spikes now well you
have all the points so I have to kind of
knock those points down a little knock
you down a little bit stop
it I'm going to punch everyone in the
face and that's one of the great things
about playing the game on the couch
right is that you're sitting right next
to the people that are uh griefing you
so we might have an on air fist
fight will that be a first for you
guys so we got an exclusive today uh
on here so uh yeah now you could just uh
grapple up to the rest of us use this as
anchor points and then we what's that
can we have
it I want it I want it I want it I want
it I'm bad at balancing can't get up
there little stand
orbs totally Ste help guys can I get the
grap oh yeah he needs a grapple you need
a grap yeah no I'm just totally leave
you behind now come back oh look there
gems over here
I yeah
I'll be nice will you
though for you made this game you know
oh no is this a Chase sequence this is a
Chase yeah okay so here's a hand don't
try shooting at on it she'll just run R
run she does eat Souls mhm oh oh my God
there's spiky things here so don't
forget you could use x uh to
roll no no okay I'm going so if you die
just hit a and you can respawn right
back in right right in front of where am
I okay yellow I'm yellow I'm yellow y my
God oh my God oh my God no no no I'm so
bad at these so bad at these so bad at
life we're going to go for the power
up I'm just running I'm going for gems
up for me I'm all about the
money oh she's catching up oh God it's
every man for
themselves SP logging damn it where am I
oh no literally respond I respond into
the spikes that's I respond
into the spikes the most heinously
spiked oh you bombed me like oh that was
unintentional
that I bomb myself
we we got to use teamwork teamwork give
me the teamwork climb up climb up all
right grapples grapples gra no no no not
each other there we go all right I got
go you got this all right
okay only moderately scathed yes yes so
that's just the tutorial uh oh well okay
bye he goes uphill from
here see you later fantastic hair Gator
mhm rocking that nice Lion Man there
Inc all right so we just uh escaped the
the Temple of Osiris here uh and uh Seth
that bad guy that we saw earlier he kind
of corrupted all of the old gods of
Egypt he's stealing their powers from
them including kepri is this huge scare
Beetle that uh he'd pushed the sun
through the underworld and across the
sky and because he corrupted him he's
now plunged the world into darkness uh
so we need to get Osiris's help in order
to uh basically take control of the day
and night cycle back and um defeat
Kei it sounds like you guys have a lot
of like Egyptian methology going on here
did you have to like read a lot of stuff
like well all of the uh all the
different uh enemies the the bosses the
mini bosses in the game these are all
things that are pulled directly from
Egyptian lore um even the prophecy of
Osiris in this case we've actually got
Mara uh going in and she's fulfilling
that prophecy of reassembling Osiris and
uh casting setback into the underworld I
feel like she be the one to do it if
anyone so uh yeah she's she's quite
literally living the myth right now so
AR you guys just like kind of doing all
this in vain because you know that Laura
is going to get all the glory in the end
anyway well they're all sharing the
glory here I mean think about Isis
and I've never seen a g Carter's in it
for the treasure as well yeah he's
totally
uh oh eat it bonesy yeah so this guy um
he's actually uh got this chest piece in
that's actually our first piece of
Osiris so um this one's a little bit of
a give me but uh yeah we our Quest is to
go through all the different TBS around
here look who's getting it it's always
such a diva her name is on the box I
need my name on the box to get oar's H
CH it's her Adventure we're all just
along for the ride that's my husband's
chest we're there we're there the
griefer as well this is Lara's World
okay we're just living in it she just
lets us
exist you guys are lucky to even be here
and of course uh Osiris he wants to to
be rebuilt so uh we have these different
statues that are throughout the world
and uh our Egyptian friends they can use
their staff again with a left trigger
and uh you'll notice the little statues
pointing the way to the next
Tomb it's over there which is
conveniently conveniently right there
yes he's like that
way it also helps to you know have these
statues so we know what pieces go where
just in case just in
case it's okay you got some stairs to
get I so excited for the here someone
want to come down here and grab this
here I got you all right cool actually
give me the grab oh oh yeah you got
about that grap I don't what's happening
what am I what are we doing here I got
that person person on the ground I got
blue wait can I get a grap again I
didn't grab one last time team get the
gra so tempting so no don't you don't
you dare all right so let's go into our
first te here the rules of hospitality
only go so far here don't you dare all
right so this is the Tomb of the time
keeper anytime you pop into a tomb uh
you can actually see what the challenges
are before you go in so for instance you
could see the point challenges if we get
the gold one we get the hand cannons uh
we got those five red skulls that we
could find in each tomb and then we got
some harder ones in there like
destroying all the vases in the Tomb
killing four scarabs with a single bomb
and those give you additional Rings ammo
upgrades all sorts of good stuff I was
going to say are those the rewards you
get listed underneath if you compl them
right and then uh yeah so if everyone
just hits a we can all ready up and then
we'll go into the tomb they seem like
this is the kind of thing that you need
to come to terms with with your
teammates of what you want to go for
right because it would be really hard to
get all the vases and time oh you guys
just totally bombed uh Horus and killed
him there oh well and nobody wants to
hit me and revive me there's a skull
over here can someone come over here and
help me get this who over there all
righty there's a thing yeah so we could
just grab Magic Ball our way up there
yeah you can actually stack the magic
balls too I got you I got you nice
little hamster ball if I'm in a magic
ball and you bomb me do I go rolling
around AAL
fashion boom so if it's just one bomb it
will actually Pop the ball up if it's uh
two or more bombs it does enough damage
that actually uh pops it there so we
could in theory like push the ball other
places with
what's that so uh this one you notice
it's uh it's ticking down there so uh
makes you wonder what's going to happen
when that thing ticks down all the way
getting that smoking right now I am not
standing near that thing yes it's a time
bomb damn it so we've got this uh weak
little uh wall segment up here another
one and also has those glyphs on it too
so for the Egyptians if we hold down the
left Trigg as it starts glowing it'll
actually slow down the bomb so that's
ticking uh slower slow down and not
reset is a key difference that I learned
when I was playing this Co-op yesterday
slow down I was just kind of like
Feathering it a little bit just to be
cute and then I blew Kevin up which was
it
Wasing very c yeah in single player it's
hard because Laura has uh both the staff
uh and she has to push the bomb as well
so she can't shoot trying to slow down
whoops so yeah this little uh pressure
plate here it's extended it's opening up
ring over so one of you grap folks stand
on the plate all right that'll be me I
made this M too I was the one standing
on the plate and the grapple was
slightly off of it and then as soon as I
stepped off the plate the grapple
disconnected because of this
thing okay and that's the same thing
over here uh standing on this plate here
it extends that grapple ring up top so
that you guys can uh grapple to it and
then swing across the uh wall there or
jump to your death too I got you guys
fire bullets from gem collecting nice
thanks buddy you're welcome am I
supposed to swing back and then hit a to
jump once she get to the uh the right
there nice nice so yeah you're right
when you're playing with four player you
kind of have to choose what challenges
you're going to have to go after I'd
like to get all vases like uh one of the
challenges is um all those time bombs
that you have you have to actually push
them to the wall without ever touching
them so that means you actually have to
bomb the time bombs uh all the way to
those walls uh whoa whoa we stealing
gems again them gems you're so offended
got to get after them gems f
you got to work your gem I'm going to
grab you in the face in a second here
jump up here I'm giv I'm giving you
these Gems by letting you jump up here
just kidding there stairs
I'm oh there you go everyone's a
sucker got some more there holy moly
mine what is unless we get to it first
the
skeleton all right looks like a few of
us are getting Point challenges there oh
so I'll go ahead and uh hold down the uh
ooh nice thinking stand on top of that
oh it
moved and uh one of the other things is
if you were playing the game in single
player uh things like the uh like that
power up up there you'd have to do
exactly what we did there you'd have to
push the time bomb over there and you
could get to all the red skulls all
little powerups but if you're playing
Co-op uh you got a few more uh tools at
your disposal uh with your teammates
like the magic ball that you could use
to get up there
so and also while we're on the subject
uh game also supports drop in Dropout
Co-op so if one of you have to go to a
bathroom or something you could actually
just drop out it'll just reload the
little room that we're in uh cuz it'll
change up the puzzles for for three
players instead of four and then we can
just keep
going damn it beetles those scar beetles
are really getting go
away
okay okay who there we go what's going
on here found this little
oh there's also a grapple yeah there's a
little red skull down there oh yeah go
get this skull oh oh good
save you're the one who stepped on it
come
on and then you could just swing again
whatever your name's on the box she fine
I'll just spawn again you'll just
respawn watch out these are spike balls
are they
oh don't come over here it's fine
there's nothing over here that's cool no
Gems or anything no what's
that no
skeletons no
skeletones I was bombed what is this
green thing in the middle of the floor
I'm afraid that's a it's a health Shrine
so it's actually a good thing but last
time I stepped into a green thing I
shriveled up and died it's true um
that's
because that was a misleading shine
gems mine great you just bombed the fire
bullets
away nice
work he's kind of kind of
pissed is he in a pool a pool of magic
yeah so he hasn't made it uh fully uh
fully out of the underworld yet that's
unfortunate oh boy wow jeez oh God where
am I what happened don't forget this is
perfect spot to use your bombs in order
to uh me grievously or to everybody
somebody help uh working on it working
on it never mind oh you're down I Don't
Need No
One gems gems
gems see you later suckers no all right
I'm on it yeah but you're going to need
our help again so no you're suckers go
ahead and pull this I don't think you
heard me call you
sucker you clearly don't understand the
meaning of this what's happening oh so
uh up there we uh we that shotgun
is nice so I'll go Ahad and uh hit the
back button here let could equip that
shotgun Egyptian guns shotguns got some
dual pistols too yeah because you got
that uh gold uh Point challenge I got a
new ring oh yeah yep and if you've uh
yeah we've probably completed a few
challenges here that give us uh some
more
goodies so many goodies dang it want to
get my did I get a new tank top yet yeah
have hav't gotten a new tank top yet got
to play a bit longer does it give me
strength or is it just aesthetic uh the
outfits are just completely aesthetic so
just allows you to play as a fun
different
costume okay there we go
oh you're not the only one who's got
guns Laura guns oh I've got your dual
pistols too oh idiot did you just bomb
yourself no I did not hey where you have
nowhere to go you I think you're going
to get me huh oh no oh so one of those
Rings it actually uh increases the size
of your uh your bomb radius there so
that comes in here I guess there's a
grapple up
there yep guys there we go cool let me
check that out Neato you guys
suck P sorry I'm feeling very spiteful
because of Lara Oh you mean cuz that
time I killed you that one time there I
remember that you know just anyone else
who needs to get up there thank you very
much
I was just getting you off the Rope
that's on there's a
secret over there I got it don't worry
he just fell to his death and he's got
this but he's going to respawn back at
the beginning so we have to uh give him
a lift that's you go help almost oh my
God you guys oh oh I'm just don't you
dare don't you dare no
you who did it who did it was it was
Laura's bomb I mean it was a red Bomb so
I did I did it it was me of course it
was it's always me all right Gold Point
challenge got some hand can at first I
just wanted to do it to like so here's
another little hint
somebody it would actually be funny if I
did you could actually set off a bomb
next to their bomb and it'll set theirs
off so if they trap you like that oh um
so uh who has a grapple hook uh cuz you
can actually grapple over to me and we
could do like a little clothes line that
uh another player can jump on
to like so yeah if the third person
jumps in the middle gooss the middle oh
no oh no oh God just jump up
perfect good job you are the
worst all right so we got another bom
ball up here come be your name on the
fck doesn't mean that I got stuck I got
stuck behind these
pillar I deserve that all right so um
here's another one yes we have another
one assuming that this one goes
up mhm so uh yeah we're not going to be
able to fit it through here because it's
too narrow um but if we use the uh our
bombs here we can actually blow this
time bomb up to that other ledge there
we
go okay oh crap you're going to have to
defend me cuz I can't hold the staff in
God damn it okay I'll protect you I got
you these
bombs
ah are you holding the staff still you
can also use the bombs to uh yeah I've
still got so even though you're holding
the staff uh the only thing you can't do
is uh use your weapon but you could
still do things like uh oh crap I
totally just trolled on Laura there it's
all right she deserv all for the sake of
the team okay the team must move forward
all right I have I'm giving assault fire
bullets so maybe don't blow me up like a
horrible for murder you lose points and
you lose your multip the person uh who
died they lose uh their points so what
about the person who killed you they
don't pun in anyway their soul their
soul so all right so this bridge is uh
starting to close on us we shoot this
guy over here there we go and then yeah
we've got the um with the Egyptian
players they perfect perfect we got it
all right let's blow this
wall let's troll each other
no just trying to make an honest living
as an archaeologist I never signed up
for this never signed up for
this actually Carter's the one who's
totally in it for the treasure so well
oh playing the long you mean like what
just happened okay there we go no did I
get faster all right all right well okay
feel
fast
woo no I'm just going to jump to my
death I'm going try that
again m m no no no no no M oh horse is
down oh my God into the into the every
every hole just fall in every hole all
right managed to escape the tomb and end
of all the tombs we got another piece of
Osirus his right fist here's a hint
there's also a left
one just a big it's actually a giant
robot claw it's actually it's a
steampunk take
ony he also reassembles himself and then
uh that's problem so at the end of the
Tomb you could actually see some stats
who use the most bombs who died the most
um some golden F and then uh the players
who has uh the highest score we actually
give you bags of gems uh related to um
what your score was there can it show
how much of your score was eaten Away by
treacherous wenches I wish
whoa whoa yeah you don't got to call
yourself a winch she is treacherous
we're not here Tob to call hereb I'm the
best listen I have magical challenges
that some of us uh finished off here and
if we want to we could go right back
into this tomb and pick up where we left
off in order to find that one missing
Red Skull and then uh give you guys the
catch up on the points we did destroy
the vas all the did we did I mean you
set off on that mission to do it's I did
I looking for them all belongs in the
museum um so if you hit a uh we should
be into our treasure room here so all
these gems that we've been collecting
you see these uh chests down there and
up here I didn't get any you'll notice
uh like I could go ahead and open up
this one here and uh we have uh a whole
bunch of different chests uh so you've
got like the cheap chest all the way up
to ones that look like uh the ark of the
covenant uh up there that one's worth
like a th000 gems the other ones are
anywhere from like 100 500 and these
have additional Rings amulets they also
have weapons in them as well we're not
supposed to open the Arc of the open
them yeah so uh you'll notice right
above uh your player character it's
telling you what the cost of uh of that
chest is Jesus I can't open you imp
you can also look at the little light
that's uh glowing above the chest to
tell you uh real quick if that's one
that you can open up so the really cheap
ones you can actually uh open up right
now so try try like this one right over
by Blue um that one might be able to
open oh you got one I can't afford
anything I can't afford anything cuz
you're not griefing enough and not
getting enough of the CH you're just
mean to me found uncommon ring that's
what you get right so it's a Teem you
got like common you've got uncommon all
the way up to legendary um so the higher
end chest have a higher chance of uh
that legendary Stu will my skin melt off
my face in that cool way um um we didn't
have enough time to implement that but
it was on the list and then uh yeah if
you wanted to quickly swap out any of
your stuff put your new uh rings on
there ice projectiles yes thank you mhm
and then again those those amulet stuff
that's shared across the group and all
Stacks so I could have fire you could
have ice uh you could have poison all do
all that damage I've got the fire one on
oh yeah let's discuss this all right so
also got the fire one Alexa can you put
on my sweet ass time can you put on the
spread one uh yeah Didn't I think yeah
there you go what's the other one that
you have cuz you got a third fire
projectiles so I'll switch over to the
scattershot well where am I and then I
think uh you had one all the way Hunter
oh treasure hunter so that one um it
actually uh decreases the cost of like
opening up uh chest poor take it I'm
poor all right oh and wait I got cool
weapons so let me give myself toip both
of your rings all
right I didn't know I could even do that
reach that's the vulnerable Iron Ring Of
Reach I'm not
ready just give my all right I'm good
I'm
good I can't believe if you're playing
the game uh online multiplayer i' only
pause the game for just the person who's
in the menu uh so everybody else would
still be able to move around you could
also mix how you're playing so we could
have like two on the couch playing with
two other people online so I sucked us
up yep so if you hit B we'll teleport
back up I'll just get all the gems here
then yeah you just break all the pots
than guys we got this covered right yeah
all right just making sure oh we all we
all done here all right cool yeah Isis
out just regret and then uh we're right
back into uh the Overworld here uh and
that's actually the entrance for that
tomb again so if you want to you can run
right back into the tomb we'll see the
challenges but then we could also just
run back out uh the entrance there so uh
um compared to a Guardian of Light uh
the entire world here it's it's
connected with this Overworld so it's
pretty seamless experience it's not this
linear level to level to level so if you
hit uh a and ready up there uh we can
actually um just walk back
up the exit and we're right back here so
also I'll uh I'll hit the back button
here and switch us over um if you hit B
real quick to greedy for a second so
this is actually yeah this is a a map of
the over world uh so you saw we were in
the Pyramid of cus came out here to that
Tomb of the timekeeper and the next Tomb
that we're going to is the silver smith
over there so all the different tombs
that we start unlocking are all
connected uh in this Overworld that uh
seamlessly connects them all together is
he pointing to the next one yeah so
he'll actually point us over to uh the
next one which is actually his his left
fist so God wait he's missing a whole
big chunk of his arm we have to get he
has an he has a torso down to his like
there are separate elbow pieces actually
no elow all these little pedestals here
uh those are all the pieces of osir so
that'll give you an idea of roughly how
many uh tombs there are in the game that
we have to raid I was concerned oh and
then if you guys come over here to the
right side of the screen um there is
this cool little chest here it's nothing
inside of it right now but this is the
community chest uh so we have things uh
Community challenges so for instance if
we have the entire Community kill 1
million scarabs with bombs uh inside of
a week we'll give you a new ring we'll
give you like a gold uh plated version
of one of the weapons uh and then you
can come back to this community chest
here in order to loot it uh also if you
pre-ordered the game so if you got those
uh DSX outfits and weapons or the Hitman
stuff or the legend stuff or your season
past stuff you all find uh the items
inside of that uh Community chest so
it's the shiny
chest I like how you guys made it blue
it is the community chest after all it
is it is there's also free parking uh
further that way and a chance uh chest
no yeah where do you gamble around here
um so uh we completed that tomb and
actually unlock these time bombs uh so
now we could use that to unlock a new
section here the Overworld get out of my
way oh let's get the Hat come here come
here someone jump on my jump up on
me jump up on me jump up on me
bye Which Way guys
it's that way can I open it totally want
to have voice over when that
happen it's over there challenge tomb
yes so if you played Guardian you'll
remember that we have these optional
challenge tombs that apparently somebody
does not want to go into listen it's an
the rule is in any game you load into a
level you go back to the pointing you in
the direction go back to the entrance to
find the hidden secrets that you don't
want me to find if that's don't act like
you don't do that in other levels cuz
you guys totally do sure so is the idea
I'm going to go over here God damn it oh
okay oh there we go so yeah the the
challenge tombs they're optional uh
they're on the side but they all have a
treasure at the end of them using
usually another weapon or ammo powerups
you um this first one it's actually
pretty easy because we want to introduce
you to the concept of them but uh the
later ones in the game there's uh four
more of them hidden throughout the world
uh those ones are pretty tough they were
so tough uh some of those challenges we
actually had inside of our regular
levels and when we were doing uh like
Focus testing for the game they were
just too hard for some players to
complete
so that's why we took him out theth we
made him these things on the side of
like you know brain teers hey if you
could complete this thing we'll give you
some pretty cool loot you guys oh you're
totally running into the spikes I be
tled myself be what's up here
all right so we've got you guys working
on this oh you son of a and he
dies I didn't kill you oh here all right
it's clear go head over
there all right so we've got two
switches down oh nope down to one guys
are totally swimming there I like
swimming another cool thing with
swimming is uh this magic ball it
actually floats on water uh so you could
actually have somebody ride on top of it
like it's a
boat like oh and I tobly rolled into a
St this is my switch go find your own
switch eat you got that one one now go
to that one eat an enormous
butt you got to find my husband's butt
and then we'll talk
if I found his fist I can find his butt
is But be sure to is there a butt piece
this conversation isn't going south at
all it's technically his tors is it
anatomically correct I found Osiris's
butt all right
so that way he's going to point exactly
where it's at over there so yeah we also
unlocked a a bolt action uh rifle in
there so that was our prize for this one
I'll try
that all righty then we can head to our
next TB who did it oh yeah I should be
looking at questions you should probably
have an idea who's going to do these
next ones I refuse to move until you get
cut that out okay there we
go no one's blown me up today I wasn't
before but um I can observe chat so if
anyone has any questions please let me
know who's bombing stop you could tell
who's doing it by the stop it stop it
wait um why isn't the thing if I um oh
no I was going to say if I put a bomb
near it and then I explode it it so see
how I put that bomb there you can drop
one right next to it and it'll detonate
it Goa do like a little chain reaction
on it I love that we all run out of the
temple together like for a breast just
like the
Avengers oh no we do look cool we do
look really
cool well except for that one I have
leapt into a pit oh nice you just bombed
him in there mine mine mine mine
mine
oh this doesn't look ominous at all why
isn't this statue pointing to anything
for
us oh because we weren't using the uh
the staff uh to interact with it oh
run there go and then if we plant a bomb
on top of this should be able to crack
the
cage of course more
SCS
no yell dudes
oh
God get off my platform get off of me
man I got it I got it I got it oh
beetles killed me killed by beetles so
if you catch on fire uh you can stop
drop and roll uh so just hit the x
button it'll put that uh fire out anyone
want to like working on it they were I
just responded you guys get
on all
right no get away from me get away from
me
there we go it was worth it it was worth
it no
regrets oh God stop drop and roll
roll ah oh horse down how do we get on
the tall ones nuts oh I'm de um so with
the Egyptian characters they can use the
staff to uh raise those uh glyphs up and
then uh all right nah Isis you've got
this righted got a flaming
scars guys I'm not I'm on fire I've got
it I've got it horse for the
win and face
plant all right ooh loot explosion
me give me the loot give me the loot
loot where am I taking this ball H we
actually got another one of those uh
cages right up here I suck it what's
that can I open it can I open it uh you
should be able to afford that one oh
wait no you're the one you're the one
player who can't afford because I can't
I be I can't get any
no stop pushing me off the you going eat
Pop-Tarts for lunch there's a Red
Skull no there's a skull over here oh my
god oh we're totally going for the gems
I didn't even know there was an
objective besides
gem yeah so another nice thing is um
like uh your progress in the game uh if
we were to drop out the game uh itd keep
all your progress uh on your profile so
even if you play it as a different
character the next time around you'd
still have the same weapons you'd still
have the same
Rings If the rest of your group keeps
stealing everything you could also play
the game in single player and uh makes
it a little bit easier to go out there
get all the red skulls and uh and loot
all the stuff without everyone else uh
stealing the gr te and everything is
going to play this again by by myself
you're bunch of bullies you're all we
guys because of all the awesome looting
I did we now have fire bullets isn't
that helpful it is until we bomb you we
don't have them anymore cuz Laura Croft
is a
psychopath this is why we can't have
nice
things I let's not forget who's had
several movies made out of her name oh
my goodness the worst open don't worry
I'll just get that skull for you
guys let's just go into the next Tomb
here
it was right in front of it so this is
the uh the Tomb of the silver smith here
so again we just have to a to ready up
and we can continue the adventure kill a
large skeleton with a
Spitfire yes aep's Spitfire mhm we get
to see who apep is at the end of the
level yep so lar we just need to hit a
and uh should be good skew SC come out
of your
trailer I'm known for being
astute she's just warming up CU she's
have to tell us all about this uh this
Legend of why don't I read this for you
you guys cool please
do it began with a ball on a
bird scare be clearly be clearly clearly
but the cool thing is like all these
these cut scenes if you're wearing like
your day of sex outfit will be L your
bionic arms and her uh Jensen uh shades
on there um so we swap those all out and
all the cut would you guys mind if I
changed my gun I'm going to do it anyway
I just wanted to let you know I like
this gun better so I'm going to switch
to my you have literally four Gun Slots
you can put all the guns you even have I
don't care I only want my sun machine
gun it's the only one I actually you
only have like 89 gems barely open this
is this
sucks I'm mad ooh gems ooh gems mine I
have some
now what's up guys what's up here oh
wait you did get
me I thought I dodged it all right
scream guys no don't go in there we I
went in there in there don't go in there
because I'll kill you but um you notice
now that uh there are these mirrors here
that you can reflect the uh the light
beams off
of that's in like every movie I've ever
seen about movie ever it's a staple all
right so we have another one here um is
there a way to destroy the mirror so
that Laura
entire time so I'll lower that one down
I need a ball I'll take this thing that
says be I need a
ballot can I have a ball there you go
yes we're we're handling some business
here going you we're just trying to
progress keep pushing it push it so
Point thing go back you almost got it
see that uh no not all the other way
other way make it go to the glowing ball
giant Yellow ball I'm this thing right
there there you go a little further
little further
bless your
heart all right
whatever can someone please be a ball
now oh fine I'm just Ro's bumbling
sidekick who's not important enough to
be on the
box
go he it going after
Laura all right so one of the uh the
other challenges here is uh try and
skewer 10 of these scares with these
spikes that are coming out of the ground
oh yeah how would do you how does one do
that St on the jar step on the plate or
do you just kind of like leave them a
merry Chase until they get killed by
that's probably the easiest way to do it
uh is to uh see if you can chase them
around but obviously there's a ton of
scarabs there so I'm just going to bomb
them just going to lay on the ground
like a corpse for a while no big at
least we got some health oh we were
totally going after
you nice I'm on fire a lot good good I
don't understand have it coming you
deserve to be on fire I don't follow all
right right so see got what happened
here so we've got uh this switch over
here it looks like it's raising uh that
mirror up there so we have two Egyptians
each of them have the
staff so I think if one of them shoots
the bottom one here and then the other
one tries and Banks the uh the shot up
there I'll do the mirror this time
someone want to come over here fixed hey
Laura come over here for a sec grab this
uh thing Al so now we're prioritizing
the skulls over solving puzzles yes hey
man we got to cover our bases all right
so we have three of these spheres again
that we need to get rid of this one
unlock all right you got that one and
then if uh why don't you go step on that
plate one of you stands right hereos
it'll raise that mirror up over there
and then I can bounce this one to stay
on it you're just going to stand right
there and block the shot aren't you all
right
yay teamwork
guns gun time more loot assault
rifles I'll step on on
it wh give me the grap go
friends let go troll friends troll hey
death hey instant do I have zero points
now no I don't you know I'm working on
it I'm working on I trying to help you I
got everyone except Mary damn it so the
other thing
is the uh the Egyptian gods they're kind
of the the anti class they have the
Magic Shield uh so if you get bombed you
can uh cancel it out and uh didn't make
it well I really thought I was going to
make all right I got it this looks like
a job for Laura oh I didn't make
it there we
go oh oh totally expecting a rope to be
there no sorry sometimes we can't have
what we want just cancel that out o oh
no not naming skeleton surf Shields or
surf
board so those those surf board actually
reflect our shots as well so bomb there
you go that's one way to get rid of
them just going to spend this entire
fight picking up gems good job don't
worry we got this well the rest of us
just do all the work mhm fine more
GS here's a thing shoot the shoot the
something's
happening something's
happening here you want me to do
something with this mirror I got all
right hold on I got this I actually did
this puzzle yesterday and if you let me
just move these things
you're going to use math to figure this
out you guys ever seen Donald Duck in
math magic land it's pretty much like
that this math is literally put Putt and
I can do that it's all angles see let's
see it do it get those angles all right
I think did it like I can move this yeah
move that one Mary so that it hits the
shield to the right yeah and then yeah
hi all right Horus I'm helping thing I'm
yeah team you know just for that we're
going to give some gem Dre yeah can I
like have some treasure guys
no so uh don't forget you can use uh
your left Bumper in order to uh use your
torch and light these uh bracers on fire
and those will sometimes drop some gems
give me the
grap give me the GP you know until I am
responsible for you even being up there
come give me the grab I'm the one who's
helping them now theb I gave you the
bubble Laura you are insufferable come
on I don't understand whatever her
name's on the box I don't understand
what the problem
is wooho why is everyone upset with you
understand now no who why' you blow me
up dude collateral damage I'm so sorry
I've learned I'm just along for the ride
this crazy woman has dragged me into her
Magical Mystery Tour of pain none of
y'all would be there if it wasn't for me
we must tread carefully actually it's
Carter set off the Trap so he's the one
who started the adventure oh
well so speaking of apep you're
wondering who apep was that's apep it's
a snake why did it have to be snake why
did it have to be snakes snakes with
armor no less mhm snakes in a temple get
out of here I'm not on the plane I am on
fire god Lally not an expression of my
PR I think this is is this more of a
puzzle thing we shoot or is it more of a
we have to like okay we step on the
plate stuff happens then maybe green
person step on the plate oh yeah
yeah so he has those same Spears on him
that we've been uh one through the rest
of
the idiot oh
no see like I mentioned the you know a
lot of the game the formula for a lot of
these tombes is kind of having o there
we go so yeah you here just leave it on
there why are you pushing it off it's uh
it's putting the mirrors up I put it
there way people don't have to stand on
it multi what do we
do so um you can use those instead of
having to stand on the plate yourself uh
you can uh put that on the switch to
raise the mirror you need one more
switch so if you were playing like in
single player you'd actually have to put
the balls on to uh all those platforms
there son of a
blur shooting him green person literally
stand on the plate don't worry I'll
on fire I'm dead he fell on top of me no
you're still alive you're just burning
he fell on top of me you're burning
alive
but on top of me I died doing what I
loved shooting my
friends whoa I also use this opportunity
to say that uh you know if you're
playing with a group of friends and then
one of them is a I don't know a little
bit weaker than the other players um you
can use things like the the grapple hook
in order to help them out across things
like uh the pits and and stuff this way
they don't have to do like the uh the
heavy traversal pieces um so the game is
pretty friendly especially when you're
playing a co-op to help other
people yeah but what if all of your
friends are jerks oh I read then you
need to re-evaluate your life choice are
jerk then video games aren't your
biggest problem looking for another
multiball oh they're right here all
right so we got uh three more of uh
those spheres that we need to shoot oh
don't bite me we have to figure out how
to bank these shots all right it's got
one there but then this one's going to
probably block it
so then horse to the
rescue happening nice nice work horse
happing gems gems everywhere I see them
mine mine mine mine
mine go away
Laura should have gemmed harder it ain't
all about you you
know why is my name on the boxs shut up
we can unbox that box we can unbox the
Box they uh we should probably unbox
that box before let's leave this Tom
let's ride to victory in the sun got
five minute like five minutes ago ah
okay so maybe we can show the people
what's in the box what's in the box no
it's a face try to guess which of
Osiris's body parts is in the Gold
Edition for La cop in the temple of
Osirus touch it Laura I'm going with
hips you're the winner hips we got this
oh
hips Osiris's hips everyone loves you
the
most not last so that's uh yeah the
endam of the silver smith so it sounds
like we're not going to have enough time
to make it to uh that first boss battle
there but he's pretty cool I blame Laur
um but now that we collected enough of
these pieces um we'd actually get
control over the cycle of day and night
so we could change the world to daytime
uh later on in the game different gods
have different powers so one of them
controls rain Another One controls snow
and then you could steal those powers
from them uh as you keep uh resurrecting
these pieces taking you down yes
fascinating we'll just keep bombing your
corpse there not trolling at all we
should unbox that box we should unbox
that box let's unbox that box all right
let's do it we're going to unbox a box
so yeah uh so the game comes out uh next
Tuesday you can pick it up digitally uh
for1 1999 on Xbox One PS4 as well as uh
steam then uh we also have the Gold
Edition of the game uh and this one is
pretty cool uh cuz inside there uh we
got some goodies oh my God that's the
most yes so first of which uh we've got
our little going take her out yes go for
it we've got uh our little mini 3-in
Laura over there a that's so cute and
then we've also got a cool little art
book that has a lot of concept art that
we use for developing the game and then
uh you also get uh your own handy little
uh map of the Overworld uh that shows
where all the different uh tombs are uh
throughout she's pretty cute and you
also get this PL and you get the plastic
that comes with it uh it's a collectible
um and uh it also comes with the season
pass for the game too so uh season pass
yes so uh the cool thing is the season
pass we got some exclusive content on
that um spoke about costumes earlier so
you can actually have like uh costumes
from the Tomb Raider reboot game and you
could wear them on these characters so
you can actually have classic Croft here
wearing new laur's outfit from uh from
last year's game so pretty cool that's a
great collectible for any Laura CW fan M
great and just in case you are worried
yes the art book has a page called
mummies m i mean it's Egypt man all
right well thank you so much for coming
uh uh Laura coft and uh the T over Cyrus
next week Tuesday PS4 Xbox One steam
it's 20 20 bucks 20s 20 bucks yeah
thanks for watching and thank you for
coming yeah my pleasure
yeah
he